midis temperatures of the year 8 news
now weekend edition starts right now now
live this is 8 news now weekend edition
good morning I'm Bianca Holman we're
headed into a warming trend Sally had
Emil has the details the most accurate
weather now forecast
good morning plenty of sunshine and
seasonably warm conditions for today
temperatures expected to be a little bit
warmer than yesterday 88 degrees lots of
sunshine in store for you but we will
continue to track a couple of changes
for the next couple of days the heat
will be the primary concern we will show
you that we will have an excessive heat
watch starting Wednesday all the way
into your Friday evening Las Vegas you
can reach temperatures up to a hundred
and ten degrees and you can see Death
Valley there with a hundred and twenty
degrees possible for today not the
problem 82 degrees by noon 87 by 3:00
p.m. those north winds will stay 10
miles per hour
and coming up in my full forecast we
look to tell you more about the hottest
temperatures of the year back to you
here's the latest on coronavirus cases
at home and around the world there are
5.3 million cases worldwide in the u.s.
there are now 1.6 million 97 thousand
people have died 361,000 have recovered
here in Nevada there are 76 hundred
cases 392 people have died more people
are headed outside to grab a bite to eat
as Nevada slowly reopens from köppen 19
closures the city of Las Vegas has
introduced a special outdoor dining
spaces in downtown to help both
customers and local restaurants Orko
manna explains we fell those the
appropriate time to get outside a near
perfect night to dine out downtown from
11 a.m. to 9:00 p.m. every day the city
of Las Vegas closes these half block
sections in the Downtown Arts District
and near Fremont Street placing tables
and chairs for people to enjoy a bite to
eat
city staff wipe everything down in
between seedings to combat the
coronavirus and Las Vegas are making the
most of the electric environment people
are being socially distant sort of by
themselves and on top of that with the
tables spaced-out and the cleaning crew
being really tempted to when people get
up and leave and everybody's just being
respectful of space it's the first time
since we've been out in a really long
time so it's actually the perfect time
the weather's great I feel very
comfortable and safe tonight the new
outdoor seating space is also a way to
help boost business at nearby
restaurants as many begin reopening
during phase one we're doing the the
half capacity table seating no bars
feeding until Phase two
while indoor seating at Esther's kitchen
is limited the assistant general manager
tells me the downtown dining arrangement
right outside their doors is encouraging
more customers to come by we've been
doing about the same numbers because
people are able to get that food to go
and bring it outside and kind of enjoy
the outside you know open space dining
the city says it's their way of offering
a helping hand I think the biggest
benefit really is for the businesses
that can open maybe earlier than they
thought they would be able to as Nevada
continues its phased reopening some say
this special seating will become a
terrific new tradition may become a
Saturday night happy hour type of
situation or Cabana 8 news now governor
cecil egg has announced he has a target
date for reopening casinos June 4th he's
set to discuss phase 2 of reopening to
the state on Tuesday Sicily met
virtually with the Vegas Chamber of
Commerce on Friday he also says he does
not know when Nevada will rebound from
the Copa 19 closures but he believes a
vaccine will play a huge part in
tourists returning people are going to
need to feel comfortable when they get
on an airplane and they check in a hotel
in Las Vegas until there is a vaccine
that they that they feel that they'll be
immune so to speak from the virus I
don't think it's gonna be back totally
we certainly won't get her international
travelers back the governor also
discussed schools he says some districts
handle distance learning better than
others and it would be impossible to
social distance in the Clark County
School District he says a solid
back-to-school plan needs to be made
within the next two months
Nevada's April unemployment rate is the
highest in the nation the state
Department of Employment shows Nevada
was down over two hundred forty-four
thousand jobs throughout April with an
unemployment rate of nearly thirty
thousand that's a 24 percent jump from
last April
unemployment claims were up by nearly
200,000 since last year initial claims
are nearly six times the previous record
set in 2008 deters says it's pandemic
unemployment assistance weekly filing
system is now available after
experiencing some technical issues 1099
contract workers and those who are
self-employed are now eligible the first
payments are expected next Wednesday the
head of Peter says our economic
situation is worse than the Great
Depression the department is struggling
to get through 46,000 pending claims the
director says most of those 46,000 are
more difficult claims which need to be
looked into
the agency is working to hire staff to
help process all those claim the
director says people are still having
issues on the website and on the phone
earlier this week we were made aware
that people with some specific mobile
carriers have been getting a instant
busy signal when they call our UI call
center even though there are lines
available data recommends calling
different phone lines if your case is
pending keep filing those weekly claims
so when it does go through the back pay
dates are there if you're looking for a
job there are several companies hiring
right now we've put together a list just
for you and there's the links to apply
it's all on our website 8 News now.com
the Clark County School District is
trying to create its new normal and it's
asking for parental input sasha Loftus
spoke with the superintendent about his
efforts to involve the community one-day
protection for kids you know Frank
lamellae is considering the best options
to keep his daughter safe
you see that she's gonna go in there
Glen Oaks High School waiting to pass a
vaccine or trust you know the Sprint and
the garner that Mikey's gonna be safe as
campuses across the valley look forward
to fall the Clark County School District
wants parents like lamellae to weigh in
when it comes to kovin 19 safety we just
want to God and reach out to the entire
community
superintendent dr. hey-zeus Jarrah and
his team released this online survey
Thursday this was an effort to get a
broader of an entire community input not
only our parents our students you know
and folks that are out and throughout
the community to go ahead and fill it
out it asks what families find most
important offering options like limiting
classroom seating blended learning and
enhanced cleaning procedures obviously
for us to be able to guide our decision
making and though he still has concerns
over keeping his kids healthy lamellae
says he trusts school and state leaders
to have a good plan you know for for
aspirins to be calm you know to be safe
to make the right decision for
all of our Valley students that have a
lot of work to do
Sasha Loftus 8 News Now and a survey
Sasha spoke about the entire survey
takes about 10 minutes and to complete
it and of course it would be completely
anonymous and we've got a link to it on
our website 8 News now.com
now that is DMV is rolling out a
reopening plan there's no official
reopening day but the agency plans to
only handle services like license
renewal and registration applications
for the next 30 days driving tests those
will not be offered for now
customers should still go online before
going into an office
coming up protesting a planned event
center at a Las Vegas part plus police
searching for the driver that did this
hit several parked cars and an apartment
then drove off look at this damage
you
each treatment with Devoto is right for
you you're watching the valleys news
with Bianca Holman Sally Cara Mia and
John Creech this is 8 news now weekend
edition police are searching for a
hit-and-run driver who wrecked several
cars in an apartment complex parking lot
and happened a Friday at the Stonegate
apartment complex near in Ellis and
Sahara someone who lives there sent us
this video of the damage witnesses say a
white pickup truck without a license
plate hit the cars and then sped off 7
cars and a carport were damaged mayer
approached him Michele Fiori officially
opened an expansion to Floyd Land Park
on Saturday it includes four point two
miles of new mountain bike trails and a
BMX pump track the city's park and
recreation director says these new
amenities have been in the works since
2003 when the city was preparing to take
over the land from the state the project
cost four hundred twenty-five thousand
dollars not everyone is a fan of the
changes coming to the park protesters
rallied against plans for a new event
center they say the Event Center does
not fall under the definition a passive
recreation and would disrupt the rural
atmosphere during the ribbon-cutting
ceremony
Mayor Pro Tem Michele Fiori she invited
the protesters to her office to talk
about the project the protesters plan to
send a letter to the state attorney
general's office to determine whether
that event center falls under a passive
recreation plan County leaders are
warning people about the dangers of
leaving children and hot cars a child's
temperature can rise two or three
degrees each minute when left in a hot
vehicle from March through May EMS
workers in Clark County will call it out
to 102 times for unattended children
it's illegal to leave a child under the
age of seven unattended in a car for any
reason just ahead exotic animals trade
is a multi-billion dollar business
worldwide we'll hear from two activists
who want to stop the illegal practice in
our mystery wire segment
you
you
I hope you enjoyed yesterday's
temperatures because for today we're
expecting a warming trend yes you can
see those temperatures increasing about
6 degrees for today
those lows will show you 65 degrees
today we look to be close to those
normal conditions of 92 degrees that UV
index will remain very high for today
with that count 9.1 around that one
o'clock our area of high pressure will
continue to be our dominating feature as
this will lead us to very hot conditions
for the work week we do show you your
radar showing you very clear conditions
mostly sunny conditions lots of sunshine
coming our way and we're talking the
hottest temperatures of the year so far
we will show you what today 88 degrees
by Memorial Day 93 degrees and then by
Tuesday those triple digits return we're
expected to reach a possible 110 by
mid-week and Death Valley could reach up
to a hundred and 20 that is how hot it's
going to be now your wind speeds will
show you
light and variable conditions for today
those north winds look to be a little
bit breezy for the searchlight Laughlin
area this morning for Memorial Day we
can see Lauren calmer conditions but the
Colorado River could see more gusts
peaking up to 20 to 25 miles per hour
the lakes for today a gorgeous day of
highs of 86 degrees lots of sunshine
with north wind staying 5 to 15 miles
per hour and the mountains those highs
of 68 degrees lots of sunshine and
comfortable conditions you can see those
stores with staying 5 to 15 miles per
hour as well Red Rock a very beautiful
day with highs of 81 degrees tonight's
lows we do show you 66 degrees mostly
clear conditions with North wind's
staying 6 to 10 miles per hour take a
look at how close we are to our normal
conditions up 68 degrees here are the
next seven days once again where we do
show you today 88 degrees increasing to
those 90s on Memorial Day warmer
conditions by Tuesday and check out
these very hot temperatures once again
showing you 106 109 and 108 we have that
excessive heat watch starting on
Wednesday morning all the way into your
Friday evening
those lows will be in the 70s start
planning ahead and start drinking plenty
of water and that is your most accurate
weather now forecast back to you
up next the exotic animal trade
continues to flourish in the United
States despite it being illegal we'll
hear from two activists working to stop
it on our mystery wire segment
you
exotic endangered animal trade is a
multi-billion dollar business worldwide
in the u.s. it still flourishes because
of an illegal underground network of
breeders enjoy exotic made famous in the
Netflix Tiger King series mystery wires
George Knapp spoke with two activists
working to shut down the breeding and
fail of big cats no one knows for sure
how many lions tigers laggers and other
exotic animals are lurking in roadside
zoos and backyard menagerie
but federal officials say there are far
more Tigers being kept in cages in the
US than exist in the wild
Joe exotic is one of dozens of big cat
breeders young Tigers are sold for
thousands of dollars each then smuggled
across state lines
most big cats end up spending their
lives in cramped filthy backyard cages
animal welfare groups and activists are
working to close the loopholes and shut
down the illicit trade made famous by
the tiger King series one of joe exotics
employees had their arm ripped off joe
himself is fanta
this happens even in the accredited
zoological institutions that even the
experts get killed
certainly the roadside zoo owners and
the fly-by-night pet owners don't have
any business keeping a tiger on their
property law professor Carney Ann Nasser
helped convince federal agencies to
focus on shutting down Joe exotic and is
now urging Congress to take action on a
wider scale what is the ultimate lesson
from the Joe exotic soap opera animal
welfare experts speak to mystery wire
about the ongoing big cat conspiracy
George Knapp reporting something you
might have noticed while at the stores
grocery prices on the rise for your
Memorial Day cookout what's causing beef
and chicken prices to climb this holiday
weekend
you
you
for every bloomin thing now live this is
8 news now weekend edition burgers and
hot dogs for your Memorial Day cookout
will cost you more this year grocery
prices have been going up because of the
supply chain disruption as workers get
sick and higher demand as more people
are eating at home the price of both
fresh and processed beef rose nearly 12
percent the week ending in may 9th for
fresh chickens the increase was seven
and a half percent ubereats wants to
help your family save some money on food
delivery orders the company is launching
a new feature called family-style meals
it highlights restaurants that offer a
special meal deal or larger portions for
multiple family members the new service
will be available at all
uber eight locations by June if you're
looking for a fun socially distance
activity to do today why not go on a
scavenger hunt May 24th is national
scavenger hunt day if you've never been
on one a scavenger hunt is played by
challenging teams to find a list of
random items some games add an extra
challenge by including riddles Wednesday
we're going to get ready to celebrate
Raider fans it's gonna be Raider fans
day all day long and we want you to send
us your Raiders pictures so we can
celebrate you on air send them to us on
our social media pages Instagram
Facebook Twitter all those and of course
you can email them to us pics at 8 News
now.com and you see that email address
on your screen so be sure we want to see
you and your your black and silver in
painted faces all right that's all we
have time for 8 news now this morning
you all have a great Sunday
remember keep up with us on our website
8 News now.com